when the 20-pound uplift ends this
october is communities like those here
in baika newcastle
that are bracing themselves for the
consequences
ellen is a mum of four who like many
families in the uk began claiming
universal credit after her husband lost
his job because of the crisis
guys
she also suffers from health problems
that can make even getting out of bed
difficult
and working out of the question
now she fears that cuts to her weekly
income will come as a severe blow to her
family and others like her for me to pay
my bills and stuff yes so it's going to
be very hard
it's going to be very hard maybe they
might think that 20 pound is nothing
it's a big deal for us it does help us
through along the way honestly
even
with the
it can't even help paying the kids
swimming or buying a petrol for your car
to
rub around with them going to school and
stuff
it might help a lot even sometimes
buying with a
a week a week
mug for the kids bread for the kids it
does help a lot so without 20 pound
taking off i think a lot of family are
going to be struggling
the department for work and pensions
says around 6 million people claim
universal credit in the uk
that's roughly 3 million extra and than
before the pandemic when the 20 pound
goes it's places like the north east
that are set to lose out the most with
the joseph rountree foundation
estimating around 46 percent of all
working-age families with children in
the region will be affected by the cut
and how many children have they got did
you say four those who provide social
housing in the north east have
experienced first hand the difference
the uplift has made to tenants
it's been a real lifeline for people
they've really needed to have this extra
20 pounds a week this has given just
that little bit of extra flexibility for
them to think about how they're going to
look after the kids make sure that
people are fed how they're going to deal
with the precarity of the furlough this
is going to have a really serious impact
we know that people were struggling
already before the pandemic we know from
our research that people were having to
make really difficult decisions
about you know whether they were going
to be able to put food on the table
where they're going to be able to clothe
people clothe their children whether
they were going to be able to
heat their houses so i think we're going
to go back to that situation again i
think i would just ask the government to
think again i think they really need to
think about the impact of some of the
changes that they're going to make the
impact it's going to have on everyday
families and the impact particularly in
areas like the north east
mike medra runs this food bank in baiko
which has a specially designed point
system for people to collect when
shopping for items to lessen the stigma
of asking for much needed help he says
demand has surged during the pandemic
making the uplift even more vital
i don't know how they're going to manage
it's people people that really really
need it really need it
um
i just think i think it's a shame
i think it's been a lifeline for a lot
of people and if you're going to do it
the timing has got to be better than
this i think you've got to wait until
everything gets back to normal
um because i think if you take it away
now
you're you're setting up people to fail
the government's got a difficult job to
do because of you know it's got to start
balancing books
but you're playing with the lives that
are the most vulnerable
and and i don't think
that's worth it
it's areas like this that are key to
the government's plans when they say
they want to level level up
leveling up is a really interesting term
because this isn't going to help
this this is the sort of negative
action that will damage any good
that's that thing that's as simple as
that
you know you
you're playing with people's lives and
and people don't forget
and as boris said you know he's
he's borrowed our votes from the north
yeah and borrowing means you can take
them away as well
food banks both north and south have
told sky news they fear for families in
the coming weeks as a series of covered
lifelines come to an end not only the
20-pound uplift but the furlough scheme
and extended notice for evictions
the real economic skulls covered 19 has
left behind for households to grapple
with are about to be revealed
for many families across the uk the
winter ahead is already looking long and
dark